attenzione da domani whatsapp sarà a
pagamento
se non condividi il messaggio dovrai
pagare anche tu amore fallo tu che lo
usi tanto aspetta sentiti questa
angioletto angioletto che mi vegli
quando vado a letto condividila amore non ti costa niente ma é una filastrocca per
bambini porta fortuna buon auspicio
ma pietro ieri sera no vabbè che schifo
incontentabile vi mando il video che me
l'hanno mandato no faccina che vomita
non riesco a vederlo ragazzi che schifo ma stasera cosa facciamo io ho la mia serie tv preferita
non esco io uscirei ti va si si usciamo assolutamente ma venite da me mangiamo una pizza
ma che pizza usciamo io e te bravo ci sta
ciao edo hai saputo della festa di marco
sono 100 euro totali quindi a testa
5 euro ok va bene grazie mille mari
figurati
ci vediamo sabato
o ragazzi sto imparando  a cucinare
avete visto che tagliatelle che ho fatto
che belle ma sembrano buonissime wow raga ma stasera cinema le ho
cucinate con mia nonna quello é ragù siti é ragù alla bolognese ragaaa
ooooo quello cotto tipo per 12 ore si quello una puzza in casa pazzesca
raga ma stasera andiamo al cinema ooooo no vabbè ma grazie per la
considerazione
sii certo certo le ho fatte tutte io
edo hai visto il regalo che ti ho fatto ti è piaciuto
grz ml er ql k vlv da un ka d tmp
mmm va bene allora ci
vediamo presto
sì orgz per 1 inctr prs set cia ragazzi ma Mary é uscita dal gruppo no perché non le abbiamo
risposto aspetta che la riaggiungo scusaci no no ma fate pure tranquilli
tutto bene principessa stasera andiamo al cinema solo
per farti un piacere forse vi fate perdonare mmm
buongiornissimo come stanno i miei nipotini
buongiorno nonna buongiorno vederlo come va
la sola scuola nonna tutto bene
mi metto subito a cucinare eh allora ci vediamo domani un bacione a domani lo diciamo alla
mamma saluti nipoti miei luci delle
mia vita
saluti nonno giorgio
ciao edo volevo dirti che mi ha fatto
molto piacere rivederti ieri sera e poi
stavo pensando magari una di queste sere
potremmo vederci per una cena o un
aperitivo che dici
amo é uno stronzo é ufficiale ma chi edo l'ho visto online e gli ho chiesto se
potevamo vederci una di queste sere e sai
cosa ha fatto quello stronzo
cosa ha visualizzato e non mi ha risposto e
come fai a saperlo amo spunte blu
ciao mari allora stasera ci vediamo
oddio amo edo mi ha scritto cosa gli
rispondo elimina messaggio perché
hai eliminato il messaggio no edo era per mia
mamma scusa ho sbagliato chat (che figura di merda)
raga ma oggi che fate io sto guardando un po di
tv voi io vado in palestra fra poco anche io cacca cacca cacca cacca
no dai otta ti prego anche se non condividi con noi questi momenti va bene uguale eh
faccina che ride faccina che ride vuoi mandarci una foto
ha iniziato ragazzi cacca cacca cacca cuore ma riesci a scrivere una
parola in croce
faccina che ride faccina che ride
non si comunica così cuore cuore
unicorno ti eliminiamo dal gruppo
unicorno unicorno unicorno gallina faccina che ride
no ma Mary cambiala una foto profilo
ciao edo ne ho fatte un po ultimamente ti
piace questa tantissimo dai mari lo sai
che ti amo è stata solo una scappatella
non voleva dire niente
non possiamo dimenticarci tutta questa
storia in realtà mi sono dimenticata io
di fare una cosa di bloccarti bello no
ti prego non lo fare blocca contatto non lo fa
purtroppo siamo arrivati alla fine del
video ma se il video vi è piaciuto
ricordatevi di mettere un bel LIKE o
pollice in su e di commentare facendoci
sapere quale di queste situazioni
vi capita più spesso se non l'avete
ancora fatto mi raccomando iscrivetevi
al canale e cliccate sulla campanella
vicino al tasso d'iscrizione così non vi
perderete mai più nessun video e poi se
volete fare contenta nonna carmela
seguitemi su tutti gli altri social
quindi instagram tik tok e facebook va
bene vi mando un grosso bacio e ci
vediamo al prossimo video ciao